so just a few weeks ago I had someone on
the show from Iraq all right well I
guess we can give her first name at
least for now so we had Lube not on the
show and she's a secularist and an
atheist all the things that we all stand
up for she's a minority within a
minority I we can't get into the major
details of what's going on with her
right now but suffice to say that you're
helping facilitate some of this stuff
but these people are completely ignored
exactly and they're ignored by the
people that should care about them the
most exactly and and the fact that this
has no I mean it's been like what 15
years since 9/11 happened and it's been
the same mantra over and over again that
there is no policy change of or who
exactly the people we should start with
and we have country like Saudi Arabia as
our ally and we have Qatar that I
recently discovers funds the Muslim
Brotherhood which having slave labor way
to fill up stadiums actually like I want
to raise this point which i think is
very important i the Muslim brother is
actually much more dangerous than the
ideology of Wahhabism is because they
are able to work on the grassroots level
and also they have double phases and
what's happening is that they I want to
say hopefully traded the US government
cuz that that may say made me sound like
a [ __ ] lunatic but but they have
people say but there have been in any
places in in think tanks in on the shows
everywhere that told that told the
Western world that they these other guys
the secularists and stuff are traitors
and they're not the good guys and we
should help us so they kind of have a
blog for for a large for channels like
Al Jazeera and they have kind of blocked
this concept of secular Arab is like
they wanted to push this image of the
authentic Arab yeah of the person who so
this is we are Islamists and we have to
settle with it yeah well in fact my
policy in it that I want to change is
that we should change what we need to
settle what we're asking us to settle
with yeah when I should not settle with
Islam as she's not stirred a lot with
jihadist we have to support those who
agree with our values yeah does all of
that ring as
to you as it does to me in terms of that
we're skipping a step here we're
skipping caring about the right people
because of all for all the wrong reasons
right
yeah absolutely I I think it's it's sort
of extremely symptomatic of sort of
criticism now that that's happening and
in the left and I guess you know the the
problem with that also is is that it's
created like a vacuum where where you
have like people like Trump who's coming
in and inciting inciting so much hate
against these people
yeah and blanketing blanketing all
Muslims and and that's just feeding
that's just feeding that and stop
feeding the problem right and you come
from the academic world I mean as I
mentioned to the top of the show you got
your PhD at MIT yeah oh you're on your
way to your PhD at MIT in genetics right
so you you know your stuff you're in the
academic world do you see this I think
one of the people one of the things
people struggle with is this coming more
from the students or the academics this
or is it is it both coming it's more
coming from the students um for sure I
would say that on campus at MIT we
haven't had that much incidence but over
over the you know the T stuff at Harvard
we they've had way more way more
incidents like recently the loss the law
school had to change I think they're
voting to change their their their crest
because it features three bushels of
wheat and and there's also like house
masters now right at the dorms
they've lost their titles they're called
Dean faculty assistants or something so
you know the question becomes what
happens to your master's degree or like
master of the universe like you know
just works like that yeah you know I
opposed it something recently about like
in chemistry they you know the one of
the greatest achievements in the last
couple months was that they they
actually created a new synthetic element
that's stable so we added we completed
the seventh row of the periodic table
and and in the article they called it a
man-made
elements right and so they had to change
the word man-made because people took a
lot of offense at the word they said oh
you know this is it's it's it's
excluding women it implies you know
implies that it's the patriarchy who's
involved in this but you know in Latin
the word Manus is hand and man mean
doesn't really come from man so the
entomology I'm sure they're humans
yeah and and the entomology is you know
I mean people take offense first and and
that's the first reaction so I was
telling face all this many times like
the problem with what's happening you
know in in the regressive left movement
is is this desire to see the worst in
everybody
for example Matt Taylor the receta
scientist right who land at the comment
the probe on a comment he was sure you
know inappropriate for an interview but
the first instinct is to assume I can
you tell people what the shirt was the
this shirt had was like a tessellation
of like pin-up girls like with guns or
something it was a cartoon no it was
actually a gift from a female artist
friend right it was just a silly it was
a solution it wasn't very graphic at all
it was it's you know with I mean I
wouldn't wear it but um and he were that
you know announcing the the triumphant
achievement of his team and and
immediately just the the outcry online
forced him into tears you know when he
had to apologize and and I don't know
how you make the leap from guy wearing
shirt to just infer I mean a if I feel
like a big part of this is wanting to
see this right this racist sexist
whatever it is intent the moment you
catch something that maybe you know can
be interpreted that way they interpret
it in the most extreme way and then the
reaction starts there and then the whole
outrage
industrial complex begins online yeah
and then and then after that it's a
cycle right like there's that little
thing you find it and then blow up and
then the people will criticize the bloke
the and then they're people who are
bitching about the bitching and then you
know it's just a cycle yes so what do
you guys make of that mind reading
portion of this because psychoanalysis
PhD is out being thrown around
everywhere well because when I had the
first episode of the show is you guys
know when I had Sam Harris not he said
something about the mind-reading they
want to just find something in you which
is exactly what you just said and once
they can find the green of something now
they can extrapolate it into every which
way that they want to judge you which is
so the reverse I think of how rational
people actually operate and how
evidence-based people and people have
science at and also just compassion that
that is supposedly part of liberalism
right yeah um it should be one of the
things that we aspire to is to actually
see the best in people I don't know if
that's just me but yeah it's just one of
the things that make me sad because like
this outrage requires energy right so I
wish that some of I mean I'm not trying
to trivialize their experience or
whatever they they may think of me but I
wish some of that outrage and all these
hashtags would be used to advocate for
people like look now for people like
Ryan for people who are like I wish that
energy of so much out I mean if they got
offended by me sure yeah I wish they got
offended by women getting acid on their
faces by the Taliban in Pakistan yeah I
was there offended by bloggers getting
beheaded and in Bangladesh like I wish
that some of that energy and not like to
like tell them not to talk about this
stuff but I wish like some of that
energy at least like maybe just 10%
right and I'm not really asking for much
like I like 10% is pretty good it's
lower than all the taxes of Trampas
and 10% if they just use some of that
outrage to move that energy and create a
movement at least of solidarity I don't
want them to donate $1,000,000 or
billion dollar just a moment of
solidarity to show that we people in a
free societies side with the values that
you side with and that I mean for me
when I was living there it meant a lot
to me when people told me that right
want to replicate that to help the folks
over there who need that sense of
solidarity and I'm ganna show frickin
t-shirt doesn't it show a certain level
of narcissism too because it seems to me
that when they do this they're just
saying well I can't blame everything on
myself and now that's a problem they
won't you know what I mean if they can't
link America to something it's not even
a problem yeah so that also seems to be
a bit of the yeah I mean that is I mean
I mean if it's a look at like many of
their I mean what definition of racism
is the power plus privilege right oh
yeah because they look at suffer exam
racism they redefined racism so racism
is no longer about people hating of
people of other race but rather it is
who are the people on the privileged
side so so it has to be so at the top of
the pyramid like we talked about last
time there is a cisgender white male
he's worse than Isis right and so then
there is probably Isis because they're
brown Mel's and so they're probably the
the social media guys or mostly white
but but but the other cells is like a
pyramid and the top of the pyramid is a
white male and they think he is the
biggest problem so ironically what
they're saying actually is that you as
Arab yeah Sarah Brown schemin you could
not be racist against me but maybe no no
but I'm that someone of that an Asian
person is probably lined up it's very
complicated right next to white
privilege yeah so but that you even if
you were endorsing white genocide yeah
wouldn't be viewed as racist no because
you're you are being oppressed and that
has been actually like that there was
this case I think it was engulfed Smith
University in which one of the students
was talking about why genocide Shakur
this hashtag white genocide and then she
said this is my way took surprise my
grievances yeah because there's no other
way you could get more creative then and
then she said this is this is not
actually racist what I was talking about
because I am from accept that fact that
she lives in freaking London she is a
privileged and and she's trying to
surprise her grievances the
the people are from the upper class did
so last night in the debate did Bernie
say saying about how white people don't
know what it's like to be poor oh yeah
something of that effect I mean I did
not watch the debate because I was out
but I saw this quotes is being circled
yeah and because they will say well I
mean some of the concept I mean I I'm I
agree with some of the combs that was
called intersectionality I mean it may
accept the fact that many people who say
it are crazy nut jobs yeah and it has it
has a good concept is that the people
who are for example black have less
likely to get jobs because of their
names so it is difficult if you are a
block to race to middle class then if
you are white tries the middle class so
there's some truth to this but what is
happening is that it is mixed up with so
much baggage of [ __ ] that it doesn't
make sense anymore just like when the
when the far-right talked about we
should be fearful about all of these
things except the fact that sort of like
I'm filtration of the Muslim Brotherhood
all these things like because they're so
insane about so many other things that
like whenever there's a shooting Obama's
trying to take our guns right you know
you don't take them anywhere seriously
whatever they say so what's happening
with the intersectionality and the
people on the far left some what they
say has true third is that there are
people who are because of the rights I
mean there's studies done even like
based upon the name like if people who
have like different names if they sound
foreign or whatever they are less likely
to get employment yes there is a sense
of but when separate start to [ __ ]
up well then they extrapolated into gays
for Hamas and then yeah yeah that is
what that is where like they're like a
huge bag of [ __ ] is there like when
all of these like intersectionality and
critical race theory could literally
start defending people that would have
you because under the names are a
minority and all of these so this is
eventually gets like it's it's like
destructive when it's all this stuff
mixed together right so as three people
here sitting here that all came at
different points in our lives so I'm a
I'm a third generation American you guys
are first generation but different skin
colors and that all of that stuff we're
putting it out there we're not fooling
anybody you sort of touched on this
earlier but American exceptionalism yes
do you believe in America
optional ism because alright thank you I
do too but anything tell me why I like
this quote by Bill Clinton he said
whatever is wrong in America can can be
fixed by what's right in America and as
it stands now before the elections I can
say that yeah yeah I mean I'm I've
always been a free speech absolutist and
I think it's it's something that's just
if human dignity is to be upheld we
should be free to express ourselves
that's just I was a basic human right
and there's no other country other than
the United States that upholds that yeah
absolutely so it doesn't that directly
correlate to everything you do as a
secularist
yes know what it was like to not be able
to express all those freedoms and the
reason I prefaced it by saying that
we're all different races and all that
is that we all have the same opportunity
here right exactly exactly but people on
left don't like if you say America yeah
I believe in American exceptionalism
that's a good question actually I
haven't thought about it that I'm
putting you on the spot yeah I'm gonna
get the left to hate you even more yeah
well I think I don't good job interview
but I think I do I mean it sort of
depends on what do you mean by it
both people I look from all over the
yeah I mean I live in New York City and
I can see people from tons of countries
living together for the most part
peacefully and trying living under one
system one umbrella yes I mean I think
it's a wonderful idea I think America
itself is a wonderful idea is that
despite the fact that obviously the
history of it was not as peaceful as I
wish it to be but I mean Jefferson who
was one of my heroes called America the
it's kind of experiment is that let's
put these values and let's see how they
work together and I think for the most
part is a great experiment that that
this concept of the new world of the of
the American Constitution is that one of
the first documents I was translating
when I was in Iraq and tried to suppress
the Flyers around was the Bill of Rights
of the United States it for me it's like
my Bible is like one of the most
important project the time that it came
obviously I mean now we take it for
granted people say like freedom of
speech is a human right but before this
concept of separation of powers and
separation of charge ourselves so for me
like the most important things about the
American Constitution these are used to
be radical ideas back at the time and
establish this nation of from people all
over the world and here we are I don't
think this this can't happen in many
countries around the planet right now
from different parts of the world do you
have a different culture or background
can come together to have a discussion
about ideas right and that's that's the
power of ideas and I love that you
brought up Thomas Jefferson in this
because about a year ago I was at
Monticello which was his home and it's a
great place and they tell his story and
it's really interesting because progress
takes time so that they taught heat look
this is a man who owned slaves not only
did he own slaves he had relations with
at least one I think several of the
women so he was in effect having sex
with his slaves so obviously something's
not mean that's not right on many in
terms of slavery and women's rights and
a zillion different reasons but at the
same time he was doing so much good for
the country and so many of the ideas he
had led to goodness so it shows that not
everything is through that kernel of
evil you want to find the goodness in
people yes but and but there is a trend
nowadays to apply modern moral framework
to look at the past and you're starting
to see that with Oxford roads must fall
campaign and things like that we're
looking back into the past and now
faulting you know leaders in history for
four views they had so you know
dangerous do you think that is as
someone inserted in that academic world
I mean I I find that to be incredibly
dangerous we're gonna look back on
everybody one day as culture changes
we're gonna look back on everybody I go
out that well see another King was a
homophobe yeah you should be able to get
married or something to that effect
everybody yeah it's you know it's
starting on campus right so what Joe
Wilson School in the university they're
they're debating removing his name the
question is again it'll totally comes
down to why do you feel like that hell
you know is it is it something that's a
personal it does it feel like a personal
attack and and if we if we weigh out
every single person with that kind of
you know moral calculus you're not gonna
you're really not gonna find any um any
ideal person in the pack right there's
literally nobody and that's why I keep
saying the left just eats itself yeah
I've seen this over and over unless
you're at look we can see the way
sometimes even with Bernie they've
turned on Bernie a little bit with some
of the race issues with black lives
matter and it's like here's the guy who
was arrested in the 60s you're standing
up against segregation and things like
that so it's like you have to have a
better set of principles than something
that'll just come around and get you one
day yeah also I can talk about history I
mean they're also nice to look at the
context and the timing I mean if if
Jefferson wanted slavery to be part of
the United States he would have written
in the Constitution so obviously I mean
the guy was was sophisticated enough
that it takes time to understand what
Jefferson but yeah when it comes to mind
reading day this seems like they're
pretty good over there yeah it also
shows I guess that we have personal
shortfalls that you can somehow maybe in
the public be better than you are
personally right so he's writing all of
these things about equality for man
clearly led the groundwork to follow the
slaves right yeah and yet at the same
time at the personal level he didn't so
and now we're like bringing the
conversation global is that like for
example like eyes I've worked in the
human rights field I mean I would be
honest like for a start in Saudi Arabia
I'm not gonna Duke it for same-sex
marriage but ok the concept that gays
are human beings equal rights and then
you can build a foundation that over
time because I mean I so much based upon
many of Jefferson's readings and and
back if they eat at the life eating
itself is like there was this
congressman he's also was a Civil Rights
icon Louis his last name is Louis I
forgot who endorsed Hillary Clinton
Lewis John Louis yes so I mean I cannot
vote this election so I couldn't bash
any kind of data I want
so what happened when he endorsed
Hillary whether somebody I agree with or
don't that's irrelevant
the amount of attacks that he got from
the far left was pretty impressive about
how they are anti-racist like they were
calling him pretty racist terms right
Uncle Tom and an N word in over all of
that because he interests a candidate
they didn't like this is itself their
last eating itself right as they
supposedly be anti-racist but they're
using kill on their side of the ticket
yeah there's a quote from FDR that I
rather like it was when he asked him
what do you support the fascists in
Nicaragua hey they said he's a son of a
[ __ ] but it's our son of a [ __ ] so so
if mr. Louis Andros the candidate they
like that he's okay then that is what
the black person should vote for but if
not then he is they claim to be I mean
there is a new term called the anti
racist racists which is very interesting
yeah and I'll have double negative but
and also that'll work this through at
home and also there is la more phobia
phobia of the fear of received yeah as
Islamophobic is is now let's select they
are afraid of being perceived as llama
phobic and advocated for as little
phobia there's no doubt that that was
real all right we have to wrap up here
so I'm gonna give you the last word what
can we do what is the number one thing
we can do to help these ideas spread so
what phase I was saying about the
outrage he wish us to divert the the the
the outrage manufactured by all these
small little incursions into global
issues I think that's actually something
that he's working on on movements and
it's a very worthwhile cause because
with that we can engage people who do
live in Western democracies to be more
active and to be more aware of the
perspective of what's going on the
persecution that's going on you know in
closed societies yeah so that's for me
very a very key thing yeah and while we
have our power of freedom we may as well
use it right all right well I have a
feeling we're gonna continue this in the
green room cuz we barely I didn't even
pick this thing up all right
well for more of the work that Faisal
and Melissa do check out the global
secular humanist movement on Facebook go
to movements dot or
and thank you guys for watching no we'll
do it again next week